مثل ما تقولون في المصطلحاتكم الرياضيه من
يلعب في الوقت بدل الضائع قطر مستعد واعلن
ذلك يقولون بانكم على اتم الاستعداد لكن
هل العالم مستعد ان يستضيف بلد عربي مسلم
هذه البطوله بهذا الحجم في منطقتنا
العربيه والمسلمه
من اول ما فازت بيترشح او باستضافه كاس
العالم الدول الاوروبيه تحس ان هذا انه
بطوله كاس العالم هي حكر دول اوروبا طبعا
هي ما ترضى انه دوله مثل همم قطر او دوله
عربيه مسلمه تستضيف بطوله مثل كاس العالم
في الوسائل الاعلاميه وفي بعض لا تستحق
الرد عليه
سته الاف 1500 من العمال الذين توفوا جراء
هذا همم
الانشاءات ثم تكذبه صحيح لم يكن هناك رد
رسمي يوضح الاموره يضعوها في اط صحيح
وجهات الاعلاميه اللي روجت لها هذا الرقم
وهي الجارديان والجاردين تاسست ان هي عرضت
هذا الرقم بشكل خاطئ للوفيات للاسف طبعا
اللي حصلت في انشاء السادات كاس العالم 3
وفيات
نعميه في الرد على كل هذه الافتراءات
والابداعات الادعاءات
والتهامات
بطريقه اعلاميه او ان كانت بطرقه قانونيه
في بعضها يعني انا لا نعيرها اي اهتمام
وشفنا مع الوقت ان هذه الاتهامات من
الجهات والانتقادات ومن الجهات همم يعني
لها اهداف سياسيه اهداف نقدر نقول ان فيها
عنصريه بشكل كبير ان الدوله مثل قطر دوله
عربيه اسلاميه دوله صغيره
يشوفون انهم احق باستضافه هذه البطوله
في الدول في المنطقه بهذه الخطوات الكبيره
في هذا الموضوع الا ان الغرب حتى في هذه
النقطه لديه انتقادات وهي انتقادات وجيهه
يعني يتم التشكيك في انكم تقومون بهذا
الاصلاحات حتى تتمشوا حالكم
في رؤيه 2030 لان كيف احنا نتقدم في ملف
الامان والعماله في قطر طبعا هل ننكر ان
كاس العالم سرعت في وتيره هذه الاصلاحات
والتقدم لا بالعكس كاس العالم كان من اهم
الاسباب اللي صار في تغيير الجذري في
العشر سنين اللي فاتت ايام
الفرنسيه تم التسلل الى مشاكل عمال وهم
يعيشون في ظروف صعبه وقاسيه نتساء الحقيقه
هل لديكم فرق تفتيش هل تذهبون
لمعاينه الواقع غير الذي تقول ربما التي
تصيبكم وتكون مخلوطه
ومن 2016 لليوم قاموا بتغريبه فوق ال
10,000 حمله تفتيش على مسار كان العمال
المنطقه العربيه بمنظور همم جديد كيف
استعددتم ذلك
رحت ترجع الى قطر خلال بطوله كاس العالم
هذه راح تنسف طبعا ال- ال- الصوره اللي
كانت بترسم عن هذه المنطقه همم ان شاء
الله مليون نسمه راح يكون موجود في قطر
خلال بطوله كاس العالم هذا راح يكون سفير
للمنطقه سفير لقطر
هذا المونديال المنطقه ايضا
وتحدث من قبل وضفنا هذه البطوله من صالح
الدوله من صالح
المواطن والمقيم على على قطر وايضا بتكون
بطوله استثنائيه وتكون بطوله ايضا تشرف في
العرب
[موسيقى]